so my and Sasha are kind of a big deal
for a shaft movie we haven't released
we've had there been women in them
obviously but never anyone like really
that close to either shaft right who
have a really significant part of the
story and their characters he talked
about that I guess he worked at Tim's
story before obviously yeah can you talk
about the Calvin he kind of approached
you they play Maya yeah yeah yeah it was
great you know I knew Tim was directing
it and I had no idea what it was gonna
be like I was like wow Tim decided I've
read it in the trades Tim's doing shaft
like wonder what that's like and I know
he had turned down other stuff to be
able to do it so when they sent it to me
I was so incredibly curious to be like
what can they do in another installment
you know what I mean and then it was
like jesse was playing shaft I had no
idea and when I read how they just kind
of gelled all those generations together
I loved it yeah it's a really
interesting relationship with JJ because
the childhood friends it's not like the
typical love interest it's actually
completely opposite it kind of could
look like at what your impression of her
was when you first write the script and
what I first put in the script I was
really pleasantly surprised at her
relationship with JJ because it was a
really pure love that they had which is
a friendship I think every great
relationship comes from a great
friendship and I love their dynamic
where you know she was kind of his
protector in a sense there were moments
when their other friends would would be
there to kind of show him love and
appreciation but also she's a bit of a
tomboy which I really liked she grew up
with these boys I grew up with brothers
and you see her really kind of telling
it like it is and taking on these these
big moments head-on and I just had so
much respect for that they work at Tim
before has mentioned you need to be a
lot big part of comedy you get to really
have a lot of fun this movie yeah
was there a lot of I mean worked in
before was that you can't let you go do
some of your own thing or is a lot of it
just gripped her no he does I mean you
know something you know he always lets
you add what you need to and we totally
did that mirror scene that was just all
improv he wasn't really in the script
but Tim decide
he wanted to make a moment of that you
know and so we just we you know I think
that's what's great it's even our little
exchange with the gun we didn't that was
just kind of yep in character and that's
what's great about Tim is that he gives
you a lot of freedom but he always still
knows what he wants ultimately in the
picture yeah
what was your liqueurs your knowledge of
shaft before you got in this project
because obviously you might be a really
all you get for you'll probably
accelerate when Sam Jackson played him
so he would you go back and watch the
movie I did I had to go back and watch
it before my first audition I watched
the first one with Richard cuz I really
kind of wanted to know the starting
point I'm kind of set myself in this
space and then once I had booked the job
I watched his movies over and over again
just really trying to figure out where
we're at you know in the movie I
obviously grew up with it it's it's a
huge part of the african-american
culture and my family we're all big
movie buffs so we love to quote movies
so I grew up with all the little quotes
and you're next you're working with tape
next that's our next yeah I'm doing it
now yes yeah we're just or you're
starting okay start it mhm but I'm here
for this or at least a picture just
yesterday so oh yeah on set yep breaking
news you know the county
what are you doing that movie what's the
kind of um it's about a woman
Allison Janney character who who is
being investigated for the murder of her
husband and it's a dark comedy and you
have to see they could it's so twisted
but it comes from the time when comedies
used to be dark and now everything has a
happy ending with this this one stays
dark yeah which I love I saw ma that was
very calm yeah yeah